because people tell me this they say oh
yeah I'd play with Ouija boards and
crystals and weird astrology stuff but
it was all just kind of silly games and
I think when I want to play a silly game
I play Monopoly
what is it about
what Drew you to the Ouija board and all
the occult stuff I think just us as
humans we're drawn to the taboo you know
I think it's part of our nature we like
that mystery that that's why people like
horror movies and stuff and it's like
and your inhibitions are already a
little bit weakened because you're doing
all this other crazy yeah yeah I was
already I liked that that like kind of
that I like the Demonic type of stuff I
was drawn to the dark stuff not uh you
know not in the sense of hey you know
Devil with pitchfork and horns but the
the stuff that made people uncomfortable
I wanted to go into the water that
everyone else was like I don't know
that's a little crazy the secret yeah
yeah and so that was it was just
something I did with like friends I'd
play the Ouija board I started doing
psychics I started you know I went into
all that because of Buddhism is already
kind of branched that's a I would say
those are branches of that it's like
that whole world kind of comes together